378 no that's my go oh my God almost
2,000 how many unread text messages do
you have right now 760 it's not over
1,000 that's from a like culmination of
the last couple years going to the Super
Bowl it's impossible to give back to
everybody
495 what it's real it's a big week 206
okay not bad oh my God that scared the
out of me how many unread text messages
do you guys have right now one I don't
got no hit ups and it's from my dad
three like 130 too many to count 120
1268 oh that's good
269 open those things I'll get back to
them eventually hey I just clear seven
how many unread text messages do you
have right now zero I don't like looking
at notifications so I just open
everything